[Music]
oh wow
this glider doesn't have any engines or
Motors and yet I'm still able and that's
because I'm being towed through the sky
by that plane just up there the reason I
brought you up here is that some believe
that this very principle Aero Towing
could hold the secret to dramatically
extending the range of electric planes
see startup Magpie Aviation believed
that you could use a string of electric
aircraft to aerotow a passenger aircraft
allowing it to be pulled through the
skies without it using up any energy
kinda like this that's the idea anyway
but right now it's not quite there yet
so we're going to look at where Magpie
Aviation is now where it wants to be and
what it intends to do to get there but
let's start with where the company wants
to be
the idea is a passenger aircraft would
take off under its own propulsion and
climb so far so normal but once it
reaches three to five thousand feet it
would be joined by a battery plane
carrying no passengers only batteries
here's Magpie CTO Andy gessling you have
to somehow get energy up to the aircraft
as it's flying military does this with
aerial refueling but batteries you can't
just pipe the battery across the line so
the battery plane would deploy a tow
line and hook onto the passenger plane
to tow it through the skies once the
battery plane is low on energy it would
disconnect and a new fully charged
battery plane would replace it repeating
the process until it's time for the
passenger plane to descend and land
Magpie says that this could drastically
extend the range of an electric plane
from around 300 miles untowed to over 1
200 miles by using a fleet of tow planes
so obviously it requires more planes now
the main difference between what's
happening here and magpies design is
that magpie's tow plane would connect
and disconnect in air using what they
call an active hook system that
autonomously navigates itself towards
the front of the passenger plane that's
where we would like to sit as a business
is to work with Partners to enable
Towing on their aircraft Magpie said
that they hope to start towing small
planes around 2025 but the company told
me that they believed there was no
reason why in the future they couldn't
tow a single aisle jetliner like an
Airbus A320 or a Boeing 737 as their
technology would remain a relatively
fixed sized no matter how big the plane
the physics of the problem actually gets
slightly easier at that scale but that's
all in a hypothetical future so coming
back down to Earth where is the company
today
graceful well Magpie told me that step
one is to prove that this idea can
actually work because if you think the
idea of Towing planes through the sky
sounds a little bit far-fetched well so
did Andy we threw this idea in the trash
bin several times before we started
company but we kept coming back to it
and saying we can't actually prove that
it won't work we got to the point where
we couldn't disprove it without actually
going and trying it to conduct those
tests the company bought some small
planes and developed its prototype
active hook that's where we started
we've demonstrated that first aerial
reconnections that we're aware of uh in
in March but that's just a small toe
plane connected to a glider so what's it
going to take for magpies Tech to tow
commercial passenger aircraft well
firstly the company needs to prove that
having two planes autonomously connected
for hundreds of miles through varying
atmospheric conditions can be safe we're
trying to prove out the the technology
in increasingly severe environments
right then Magpie will need to get its
Aero toes certified but as the company
doesn't have any plans to develop its
own planes just the towing mechanism it
will also need to find a willing
electric aircraft manufacturer to
partner with and right now electric
planes are yet to take off in a big way
even if when they do take off there's
still questions around the economics of
Towing as each towed flight will require
a network of multiple tow planes with
crew distributed around the country but
unlike those Aviation startups that are
making a plane from scratch the one
thing that Magpie might not need is
millions of dollars in investment the
nice thing about you know our core
technology is it's not very Capital
intensive as compared to a clean sheet
type certificate for a new electric
aircraft
so for Magpie aviation's Aero Towing to
become a reality the company is going to
have to receive certification work
closely with an electric plane
manufacturer wait for electric flight to
finally arrive and even after all that
they'll need to convince aircraft
manufacturers and passengers the Aero
Towing can be a safe and economical way
to get from A to B if all that happens
then there is a chance that Aero Towing
could be used to extend the range of
electric planes and if it does it could
be one advantage to passengers without
the engines roaring it's lovely and
peaceful up there
foreign